hey guys how's it going i'm justine
welcome to ij liked the show where i
talk about things that i like or things
that you guys have liked that you've
told me to like suspicious vicious cycle
so this past week was a little crazy
because i was out of town so i'm finally
back i have missed my white wall and
i've missed playing call of duty of miss
simcity i feel like
actually it's true i haven't played
video games for over a week so i started
twitching on the plane i was like my
xbox is near
i
uh
well i guess i'm excited or i'm sad
because youtube officially announced
that they're shutting down at midnight
tonight so all of the videos that we
have all posted in the past however
since 2005 that's a long time
they are now on the hunt for the best
video ever and i've been nominated so my
strategy from day one has always been
post as many videos as possible i mean
it's all about shots on goal i'm just
really hoping that i win because in 2023
they're going to be announcing the
winner of the best video ever and then
they're deleting every single video on
youtube remember get all of your last
minute submissions in by tonight
at midnight next up i'm not really going
to show you this video or i mean i want
to show it to you but i don't really
know if some of your little weak
stomachs could really handle it when i
saw this video i was
like and then i watched again and i was
like
and then i watched it again and i was
my sister texted me and i'm out of
dinner and she's like look up kevin
where injury so i look it up
completely
if you do actually want to see this full
video i'm going to post a link in the
description best wishes to kevin and one
of the things that i think is most
amazing is what a team player he
actually is basically
chin out of your skin is telling the
rest of his team good luck and to win
without him like are you crazy i'd send
you flowers and a get well soon card and
probably some candy but i don't have
your address tech and gaming luigi's
mansion is out for 3ds i don't have it
yet because i've been traveling i forgot
my 3ds so today that's what i'm going
out to get if any of you guys have
actually got the game let me know how it
is in iphone news we'll see if there's
any cool apps i've been using
nope
now
what's this no oh actually there is one
it's called comic book so you can create
little comics out of all of your photos
and you can even add like filters you
can add different types of layouts and
you can make little um comics now last
but not least is the style and beauty
i've been absolutely obsessed with these
spiky iphone cases i found this in just
one of those random cell phone kiosks
that you see on the street and it also
can double as a weapon so if you mess
with me i will mess with you back also
some of you who
who have been watching my videos for a
while know that not only am i obsessed
with camo but i'm also obsessed with tie
dye i got this tie dye shirt at guests
they have three different colors and i
also got oh my god i think i broke my
leg so tie dye
leggings from h m oh god i think i
pulled something thank you guys so much
for watching this episode of ij likes if
you guys have anything that you would
like me to like for a future episode
just tweet it to me and use the hashtag
ijlikes and don't forget to also like
this episode and don't forget to
subscribe wherever that is i don't know
i keep moving stuff here on youtube and
i'll see you in my next video
bye